it was one of the most resonant criminal
cases in recent US history
the 2012 shooting of an unarmed
african-american teenager a stark
reminder of America's racial problems
the vigilante George Zimmerman saw the
unarmed african-american teenager
Trayvon Martin while patrolling in his
neighborhood he then shot him dead
family of Trayvon Martin has always
maintained that this was a case of
murder but George Zimmerman's claim of
self-defense got him a verdict of not
guilty in court but now George Zimmerman
is going back to court he's going to sue
the Martin family as well as the
prosecutors claiming they did
irreparable psychological damage to him
because of the arrest charges
prosecution and federal investigation
Zimmerman lives in constant fear of
physical harm due to regular death
threats which often are expressed in rap
music as well as online social media
commentary this move has got the black
community furious many calling
Zimmerman's move obnoxious this is why
we will never be silent and continue to
fight for liberation and justice George
Zimmerman has punched through the bottom
and sunk lower than scum I don't care
how specific the allegations are he
deserves nothing except prison time I
fail to understand the logic
I mean how absurd can American legal
system be now the attorney representing
Trayvon Martin's parents says that this
lawsuit is reckless and unfounded I have
every confidence that this unfounded and
a reckless lawsuit will be revealed for
what it is another failed attempt to
defend the indefensible and a shameless
attempt to profit off the lives and
grief of others seven years on from the
death of Trayvon Martin and the wounds
seem unhealed for Martin's family and
for George Zimmerman and u.s. Society
also as wounds that are sore and open
the divide is getting wider